We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get the
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's [screaming]
children
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, and Isha Tarawih Tahajjud
Every recitation, you share in the
reward. For just 100 pounds you can help
teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.
Brothers and sisters, we are in Mecca
We are doing a 24-hour
live in Mecca, brothers and sisters,
where we are going to request you guys
to request duas. You might have a family
member who's going through an illness.
Family member you have lost. You might
be looking to get married and it's
getting difficult for you. Exams and you
are scared. Exams
general duas, whatever it is, anything
specific you're going through. We want
you guys to join our live on my YouTube
channel. As you're watching this video,
we're going to probably live for about
good 24 hours, inshallah. We're going to
try our best to keep the live going.
Your dua request will be sent through
the YouTube private chat. And then what
we will do is we will get our team to
head closest they can to the Kaaba and
make dua on camera. This will be
recorded. So, for example, sister Aisha,
she's got a kidney issue. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala cure sister Aisha's
kidney issue. I'm going to say Brother
Ahmed is looking to get married. May
Allah grant Brother Ahmed a righteous
spouse. It has to be concise to the
point. So, when we release this video,
we're going to have on the live Sheikh
Othman Farooq, Brother Akhi Ayman, and
many other people join us throughout the
live. We will also be doing fundraising,
which is separate, which is to do with
our salah project, which is guide the
salah mats. And in the meantime,
brothers and sisters, what we're going
to do is throughout the live, right at
the end of the live and between the
live, we're going to show you those
actual duas being made. So, this is your
chance. While we're in the holy lands,
we didn't want to forget the ummah. We
wanted to remember you guys wherever
you're watching from. Join the live, go
to the private chat and in the private
chat, inshallah, brothers and sisters,
you can request a dua. We don't want
anything from you. There is no catch
like, "Oh, if you donate I will do it
inshallah." Nothing like that. All we're
saying is we're doing our fundraising,
which is
separate. We're just asking you guys to
request duas concisely to the point,
inshallah. And that's it. Sheikh, what
message would you give to the people
that are watching, inshallah? I would
say
Ramadan has gone.
We have three nights left. Inshallah,
increase your ibadah in these three
nights. If you haven't done Tahajjud
yet, do Tahajjud. If you haven't recited
Quran yet, recite Quran. If you haven't
implored Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
ask him, ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Drop tears and ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. You do not know if the night of
decree is is that night and your dua may
be accepted by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So, do not waste these times.
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
say, "Woe woe to the person
who
comes and he doesn't
and he's
not forgiven."
Subhanallah. So, so these are times of
forgiveness and say what the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam told to Aisha
to say, "Allahumma innaka afuwwun
tuhibbul afwa fa'fu anna. Oh Allah, you
are oft forgiving
and you love forgiveness, so forgive us.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala accept
from all of us. May Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala forgive us. May Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala elongate our lives until he is
pleased with us."
Sheikh, come here. In the meantime
brothers and sisters, don't forget
Laylatul Qadr could be any of these days
for those who started live early or not.
So, seek it every day, brothers and
sisters. One thing I'll try to advise
you guys, which I do, you can download
the Salah Pro app. It's for free. It's
absolutely for free. Do the tasbih, the
adhkar. Do istighfar. Istighfar. And
Sheikh, come here in the meantime. So,
Sheikh is going to join us on the live
as well, inshallah. This is Sheikh
Hashem's son. May Allah bless him. He's
a solid solid fundraiser. I love him. I
love him. Bless him. He will be making
dua for you guys as well, inshallah. But
just to tell you guys, try to do
istighfar. Try to do sadaqah. Do some
Quran and qiyam. Do these four things
every single night, inshallah. What do
you want to say, Sheikh, to the people?
Tell them I'm going to make dua for
them. Yeah. Brothers and sisters,
listen. We're teaching you two pillars
of Islam. We're We're trying to
encourage you to do sadaqah. And we're
also teaching you how to do prayers,
brothers and sisters. We're teaching you
two main
>> tawhid and salah. Yeah. We're teaching
you two main pillars of Islam. Say don't
miss the live. Join the live right now.
>> Don't miss the live. Join right now.
We'll be back soon. Let's go.
Perfect. Bye.